[Music]
hey everyone I'm Brad Wolverton I head
up the editorial team here at the hustle
and today I'm joined by Zack Crockett
who's our senior editor of our Sunday
stories
welcome Zack oh yeah I just wanted to
talk to Zack briefly to tell you all
about this amazing story he's working on
for this Sunday if you've enjoyed our
coronavirus coverage you're gonna really
be impressed with what Zack found this
week so a couple weeks ago he did a
survey of our audience and was looking
for people who had survived the Great
Recession and wanted to find some
stories of lessons that they had learned
to share with our audience so tell us a
little bit about the survey Zack and
what kind of response you got yes I mean
just to start off I mean everyone knows
the the Great Recession is a totally
different crisis every every recession
in crisis is totally different obviously
this is a health crisis in addition to a
potential financial crisis but there it
is interested in talking to some small
business owners who've been through
basically been to hell and back there
there are a lot of lessons and sometimes
it changes your business in a permanent
way so we were kind of curious to to
reach out to small businesses that went
through it last time around and hear
about some of the universal lessons of
what it takes to survive a rough time in
general we you know got a couple hundred
responses from all over the place I've
basically spent the last two weeks
talking to you know lotion makers and
Scotland and farmers in the middle of
the country car dealership owners in
small town Illinois cabinet makers in
Tucson Arizona just all kinds of all
over the map all kinds of small business
owners entrepreneurs inventors no matter
what the size of your business is some
of these struggles are you know
result recessions and crises hit
businesses in very different ways but it
was so interesting to see just the very
response of how people got through this
what it was like for them
some people thrived during the recession
other people it was fighting tooth and
nail to just keep your employees on
board and pay the rent there was just a
really incredible varied response with
people all over the place anything
really stand out to you in a big-picture
way Zach that you found that's that
could be universal universally
applicable or helpful for people well a
couple of things one of the questions we
asked in the survey was whether people
were defensive or offensive during the
recession and the response was actually
pretty interesting it was almost a 50/50
split it was about 6040 offensive
defensive so I didn't really see a major
trend with wit strategy with them
fundamental strategic approach you know
I also asked what they would have what
kind of characteristics they had to
adapt to survive we saw a lot of cost
like severe cost-cutting down to five
ten dollars monthly expenses just total
red lining of budgets and and going
through things with a fine-tooth comb I
saw a lot of pivoting flexibility was
really big that cabinet meant sure that
cabinet maker from Tucson I mentioned
considers himself an artist he's one of
the preeminent furniture designers in
the area really respected very high-end
furniture
and during the recession he pivoted to
bill cabinet he basically became a
cabinet maker so he became kind of a
general contractor more than an artisan
and you know in the grand scheme of
things that might sound like a small
cost to pay to survive but it took a
tremendous amount of time and energy and
effort to be able to make that pivot
it's like it's like me a tech reporter
just being having to learn how to report
on science over night or something it's
a completely different thing so yeah we
also saw you know some people took made
a very difficult decision to go to
double-down and go all in and expand
during the recession I think the car
dealership owner I mentioned the auto
industry was hit incredibly hard used
car sales dramatically decreased which
is one of the biggest revenue drivers of
any car lot and instead of cutting costs
he decided to double down on his used
car inventory and use it as a time to
bulk things up and then when things
started to shape up again he was able to
outbid a lot of his competitors on the
priced used cars so it's one thing I
learned in the last few weeks just
talking to so many people is it's hard
to find universal blessings because
business is just so personal and
subjective and it's such a labor of love
that every situation is different but I
think that there were a lot of things
that came out of this that even hedging
that this is a very different situation
and there are all kinds of businesses
many people could apply to their own
situations right now makes sense well I
don't want to spoil it for you because
you have a lot more you're gonna tell in
your story you're gonna talk to a lot of
people and tell their stories make sure
you open our email on Sunday I didn't
want to tease one more thing there are
lots and lots of people who have told
their stories and we have a database of
these people and we're gonna do
something pretty special with it too so
we've got some plans for that
not exactly ironed out yet but we're
going to be able to offer that
people to learn some of these lessons as
well so anything else you want to say
Zach well you want to tell me about
what's behind you there besides that the
beautiful guitar what is that your
outline taped up to the to the wall yeah
sometimes I'll print out my my outlines
my stories and just go over it
physically it helps a little bit it's
it's just hard to work it as anything in
your head sometimes when I saw on a
screen
toggling back and forth between tabs and
spreadsheets
it's nice to hold something in your hand
sometimes and look at a physical
document very cool well we have you have
a ton of fans out there maybe we should
do a separate segment on how you
actually put one of these toys to go
sometime so that will save that for
another time but thanks for joining us
today Zach and everybody make sure you
open the email on Sunday
[Music]